[Música]
[Aplausos]
o passado não existe mais
o futuro ainda não chegou o nosso
encontro com a vida acontece no momento
presente
e essa mensagem que eu trago para vocês
agora
a vida acontece no momento presente
nós não podemos viver no sábado nós não
podemos viver no futuro
daí uma questão importante agora sempre
todos vocês têm facilidade de manter a
mente no aquino agora somente de vocês
vive preocupada com o que vai acontecer
daqui a pouco ou vive remoendo aquilo
que aconteceu no passado
acontece de vez em quando com alguém ou
de vez em sempre
então a solução bem imaginem uma pessoa
com 30 anos de idade que vai viver até
os 80
essa pessoa tem 50 anos pela frente
essa pessoa passa em média oito horas
dormindo e 16 horas acordada todos os
dias
só que dentro dessas 16 horas que ela
passa acordada ela só está réu
ela só está realmente inteira no momento
presente cerca de duas horas por dia
essa é a nossa média atual e vocês sabem
o que isso significa
dos 50 anos que ela tem a frente ela só
vai viver de fato cerca de seis anos e
alguns meses
são anos perdidos dentro de 50 44 anos
de momentos de oportunidades de
aprendizados desperdiçados um susto
quando a gente olha essa informação
daí a gente é a seguinte conclusão
a atenção plena viver o momento presente
não é somente importante é mais que
importante é fundamental
qual a diferença de importante pra
fundamental
uma coisa importante pode ser
substituída por outra coisa importante é
aquilo que é fundamental não pode ser
substituído
então se a gente reconhece que tem uma
dificuldade de manter a mente no ac no
agora e reconhece também que para viver
de verdade a gente tem que está agora a
gente que buscar uma solução a gente tem
que gostar um buscar um meio uma prática
para que a gente consiga efetivamente
manter a mente no agora e aproveitar a
vida de verdade com tudo o que ela
oferece
por isso desenvolveu um método chamado
mapa deva hoje eu busco naturalmente
viver de acordo com esse método ensino
esse mesmo método mapa deva significa
método de atenção plena pacificação
emocional desenvolvimento pessoal e
autoconhecimento
eu vou passar para vocês agora os
ensinamentos da atenção plena
segundo uma patativa falamos viver no
momento presente é fundamental mas daí
surge o primeiro desafio
muitas pessoas entendem que viver o
momento presente é a mesma coisa que
viver o hoje mas isso é um grande
equívoco
hoje é um conceito que implica em 24
horas dentro do hoje tem manhã tarde e
noite
por exemplo eu posso estar neste momento
pensando em alguma coisa que eu fiz a 2
horas alguma coisa que eu tenho pra
fazer daqui a pouco eu tô dentro do hoje
mas eu estou perdendo esse instante
então é a primeira coisa que vocês devem
compreender em relação ao momento
presente
o momento presente onde a vida acontece
não é hoje é este exato instante e esse
instante é aqui e agora porque essas
duas palavras são importantes e não
somente agora porque nós podemos estar e
isso acontece com muita frequência
sintonizadas com agora mais perdendo
aqui quando eu estou aqui mas pensando
em alguma coisa que está acontecendo em
outro lugar
vamos supor que o flamengo estivesse
jogando agora ea mente flamenguista
fosse lá para o maracanã vai ficar se
imaginando quantos gols o flamengo já
fez que sempre faz eu estaria conectado
com agora mas estaria perdendo aqui ea
vida acontece aqui
dessa maneira a gente define o momento
presente é esse instante e é aqui e
agora
daí surge a pergunta mais importante de
hoje dentro da minha fala como fazer
para manter a mente no aquino agora que
ninguém se distrai de propósito
ninguém fica viajando entre o passado eo
futuro porque quer é uma inabilidade a
prática que traz a gente para o momento
presente é a prática da ação consciente
a respiração consciente traz a gente
para agora e eu proponho que vocês
pratiquem comigo
peço que apóie os pés no chão coloquem a
coluna ereta e respirem com consciência
respirar com consciência significa
sentir o ar entrando e saindo do corpo
sentindo ar entrando e saindo do corpo
sintam o corpo se sintam presentes no
corpo
e também sinta um contato do corpo com o
auditório a cadeira com o chão mesmo
tempo presentes no ar entrando e saindo
do corpo presente no corpo e presentes
no contato do corpo com vitória
presentes no contato do corpo auditório
vocês estão aqui a mente no agora se
vocês fizerem essa prática pelo menos
cinco minutos todos os dias vocês
habilitam para o seguinte dentro da sua
rotina durante as suas atividades sem
vocês perceberem que ele ia dá vontade
de vocês e às vezes até mesmo fazendo o
mapa a mente de vocês priva vocês da
vida se projetando para o futuro ficando
presa no passado vocês podem repetir
assim o passado não existe mais
o futuro ainda não chegou a vida
acontece no momento presente
voltem a atenção para a respiração sinta
um corpo sintam o corpo onde ele está e
se envolvam com que o momento presente
oferece a respiração consciente
olha que bonito reconnect a gente com a
vida foi combinado fizeram direitinho
daí a gente tem que dar um arrocho até
mais bonita
daí a gente tem que dar o nosso próximo
passo depois que eu trago atenção para o
momento presente dentro da medida do
possível eu faço uma coisa de cada vez
quando eu faço uma coisa de cada vez eu
trago uma qualidade pra mim ação
eu trago mais segurança e mais
excelência
vou dar dois exemplos pra vocês o
primeiro exemplo
é do sujeito que está dirigindo e ao
mesmo tempo está falando no telefone
celular ele não tem segurança
fazer uma coisa de cada vez traz
segurança
o segundo exemplo é do pai que está
sentado na mesa da sala olhando o
computador trabalhando e de repente tira
os olhos da tela e fala filha vem cá
tá chegando o seu aniversário que você
quer qual presente você quer viajar
você que é uma super festa e ela diz não
papai eu não quero nada disso
eu quero que você me der um pouquinho de
atenção
[Música]
a gente só pode desempenhar bem uma
função seja profissional ou seja
familiar quando a gente está realmente
presente naquilo que a gente está
fazendo
então além de fazer uma coisa de cada
vez a gente acrescenta uma outra
qualidade que a mente principiante mente
principiante significa vivenciar o que
está acontecendo aqui agora sempre como
se fosse pela primeira vez quando a
gente faz alguma coisa pela primeira vez
a gente faz com mais cuidado com uma
atenção mais refinada mesmo um versando
com aquela pessoa que você vê todo dia
ou repetindo aquela ação que faz parte
da sua rotina coloca a mente de
principiante porque a ela impede que a
gente olhe para o momento presente com
os olhos do passado mas somente de
principiante que gera uma abertura na
mente para a criatividade
a intuição para o insight
a visão clara eu vou trazer um exemplo
pra vocês eu tenho certeza que todo
mundo aqui já ouviu a seguinte ideia o
tempo cura tudo correto
possivelmente já até repetirão mas
quando a gente começa a praticar a
atenção plena e chega na mente de
principiante
é evidente que o tempo não cura
absolutamente nada
alguém já viu o senhor tempo se
aproximando de uma pessoa e curando essa
pessoa já o que cura é a expansão de
consciência é o amadurecimento é a
mudança de hábito é fazer o tratamento
que o médico prescreveu e isso pode
levar algum tempo mas o tempo não cura
nada
existem pessoas que em momentos de
sofrimento de aflição lembram dessa
idéia é o tempo cura tudo e ficam
esperando o tempo curar só prolongam o
seu sofrimento até resolverem tomar uma
ação e dessa ação pode vir a cura
então vejam como é precioso o processo
da atenção plena chegando na mente de
principiante nos auxiliando a reaprender
a aprender a mente de principiante
liberta nossa mente dos condicionamentos
habituais
por fim eu vou compartilhar com vocês os
benefícios mais importantes da atenção
plena que são despertar de uma
consciência pacífica e o despertar de
uma consciência amorosa medo preocupação
ansiedade
isso tudo tem relação com o futuro que
ainda não chegou
mágoa ressentimento culpa e isso tudo
tem relação com o passado que não existe
mais
quando a gente desenvolve essa
habilidade está realmente inteiro nesse
instante aqui agora a gente desperta uma
consciência de paz
e essa consciência faz com que a nossa
mente fique permanentemente calma serena
não reativa daí a gente olha para as
outras pessoas com mais profundidade
a gente olha pra gente mesmo com mais
profundidade e é natural é espontâneo
revelar os valores do amor
da paciência da compaixão da tolerância
porque a prática da tensão plano coloca
a gente em contato com a nossa essência
mais profunda ea nossa essência mais
profunda a mesma essência que permeia
absolutamente tudo que vivi e as
essência é puro amor
quando olhamos pra existência com
atenção plena
descobrimos isso olhamos o sol o sol
brilhando o sol não brilha em benefício
próprio o sol brilhando nos oferece luz
calor energia vida podemos olhar também
para um rio correndo e descobrimos que
ele não corre pra ele mesmo um rio
correndo se oferece como morada para
inúmeros seres mata nossa sede viabiliza
a vida na floresta
podemos olhar para uma árvore crescendo
e também percebemos que ela não age em
benefício próprio ela nos oferece frutas
flores oxigênio enfim quando olhamos com
atenção plena para toda a existência
descobrimos que a existência é a
materialização do altruísmo ea
inteligência que existe por trás do
altruísmo é inteligência do amor à nossa
essência mais profunda é puro amor eu
proponho um exercício para que seja
feito a cada instante para que a gente
consiga manter a nossa mente em harmonia
com a sua própria essência
o exercício é o seguinte sempre que
vocês perceberem suas mentes surgindo a
ideia o que o mundo tem para oferecer
como eu posso me proteger do mundo vocês
substituam
o que eu tenho para oferecer para o
mundo como eu posso proteger o mundo
além da evidente nobreza nessa mudança
de paradigma
vejam o resultado disso quando eu
pergunto o que é que o mundo tem para
oferecer
eu olho pra fora e coloco a minha
felicidade na dependência de algo que
não depende de mim mesmo mas quando eu
me pergunto o que é que eu tenho
oferecer para o mundo eu olho pra dentro
de mim mesmo e buscar aquilo que existe
de melhor dentro de mim mesmo e o que
existe de melhor em mim mesmo é o amor
praticando assim a gente vivencia os
nove princípios da atenção plena de
acordo com uma pá de viva a vida
acontece no momento presente o momento
presente esse instante esse instante
aqui agora conquistamos aqui agora
respirando com consciência e respirando
com consciência fazemos uma coisa de
cada vez
fazemos uma coisa de cada vez comumente
principiante
daí nos libertamos dos condicionamentos
despertamos o cuidado amoroso e vivemos
integrados à essa inteligência que rege
absolutamente tudo
todos aqui temos o mesmo objetivo a
felicidade ea felicidade tem uma
condição uma base a paz
a gente pode estar embaixo mas ainda não
está feliz mas a gente não pode estar
feliz sem estar em paz ea paz existe na
dependência do amor a paz é fruto do
amor
por isso meus queridos pratiquem atenção
plena
vivam para despertar essa consciência de
amor promovam a paz sejam felizes e
principalmente para justificar esse
título maravilhoso que todos nós
recebemos de seres humanos vivam pra
fazer outras pessoas felizes gratidão
pela atenção de vocês
[Aplausos]
[Música]